now another baffling moment for the ever
weak the frail
the cognitively struggling joe biden
today because after telling
the american people they must wear their
mask you must wear two masks
fauci is now saying first it was no mass
then one mask now it's two masks
what did biden do well we'll let you
decide take a look
i want to make something really very
clear this is not a time to relax
we must keep washing our hands stay
socially
distanced and for god's sake for god's
sake
wear a mask whatever happened to your
promise
seven weeks ago that if democrats
flipped the senate the checks were going
out the door
come on peter thank you let's go guys
thank you
so much
you see what i saw he just lectured us
about wearing a mask
hey joe you forgot to wear your mask
let's be clear
from our own observations as we've been
saying i know it's ticking off the mob
in the media but
sorry i can run tape at joe biden four
years ago 10 years ago
it is noticeably different many liberals
privately tell me
even media mob people have told me yeah
uh joe every time he speaks they're like
on pins and needles scared to death if
he had a fastball it's gone
and now he's lost a slow pitch look i'm
not at all making a medical diagnosis
never will
it's not what this is about it's not
about age bernie sanders has a ton of
energy
donald trump has the energy of a hundred
people a thousand people
a pattern of behavior we've documented
it night after night on this show
and we're not talking about a few gaffes
it's about increasing evidence
of a well total lack of any energy
and let's just say not particularly
aware
lacking awareness nice way to put it
by the way you can imagine what the mob
and the media's reaction would be if
donald trump
approached those doctors without his
mask on you know with reaction former
white house chief of staff mark meadows
what a difference a month makes my
friend
um and i'm i'm watching this
it's really though more about policy
you know i go through the list of the
world health organization the paris
accord
stopping construction of the wall not
enforcing immigration laws you know
by the stroke of a pen bypassing you
know an
entire co-equal branch of government
executive actions on everything
what's your reaction to this first month
well that's what he continues to do sean
when you start to look at this
this is not only uh not unifying
uh in working with congress he's doing a
go it alone
america last kind of approach and so
it's some of those policies but it's
interesting you know
we we look at that we see how the media
continues to give them
a pass and give specifically joe biden a
pass
you know whether it's the mass today
that we're looking at
and by the way when you look at it it
looked almost like kamala harris
actually said
hey joe get your mask you know and he
went running back and so
uh when we when we see all of this
though it is very very important
that we start to focus on what joe
biden's all about
he made campaign promises the media gave
him a pass
and yet what we're seeing is is that in
individually he is continuing to put the
american worker last
and they're suffering for it you know
i'm watching all of this and i'm i'm
i'm talking to people every day on the
radio people are really really nervous
you know sometimes you get a better
perspective standing back from the
election standing back from all that
happened post-election standing back
from impeachment madness
democrats again and the one thing i
think
and i might be mistaken and i i think we
might get the first
evidence of this on sunday when the
president speaks to cpac you would know
more than i would
but i would expect that we're going to
look at
president trump's first term as the
beginning
of of the america first movement as the
beginning
of making america great and it's going
to be a process
and it's going to be long-standing and
it's going to be ongoing and it's going
to be a daily battle
make sense well you're going to see a
speech on sunday that talks about not
only the beginning
but what the future may look like and
i'm i'm excited about it
i spoke to president trump last night
for a fairly lengthy conversation where
we're talking about
america where it needs to go continuing
the america first agenda
but more importantly than that how this
uh president biden has undermined
that particular policy within days
and we see it listen we talk about
following the science joe biden said he
was going to follow the science let me
tell you what he's doing he's following
the money
you know he keeps the schools closed
he's letting teachers union
dictate it yet but when it comes to
other union jobs
like pipeline jobs he's eliminating
those right away
and he's going against campaign promises
but what we will see
on sunday is we will see the the start
of planning for the next
administration and i can tell you uh the
people that are at the top of that list
all of them have trump as their last
name you know i i think back look at for
example the travel ban that
that biden calls historical xenophobia
in january
or february and in march of last year
right
and then you think about when when
really things got
bad in late march and new york was
caught flat-footed and new jersey was
caught
flat-footed trump built the hospital
manned the hospitals converted him to
covet
got all the ppe all the medicines the
beds remained empty
and then people were dumped as we now
know in nursing homes by the
by the great uh governor cuomo with his
fantastic power points that weren't so
powerful after all
and then we have the vaccine this is not
the biden vaccine
you guys were distributing a million
shots a day into people's arms when you
left office
for weeks before you left office now
they're having a hard time picking up
the job that you guys already put in
place
i think history will be kinder to donald
trump's travel ban
what he did to build hospitals and the
warp speed vaccine
well without a doubt i mean he protected
americans
but isn't it interesting how everybody
said
oh president trump when he's out there
saying that we're going to have a
vaccine
in nine months we're going to do it in
record speed you know everybody
including governor cuomo and dr fauci
said there's no way that that's going to
happen
in fact they were out there doing
victory laps to try to take credit for
things that he was actually
doing but here's what we we do know is
that the president
that i had the privilege of working for
actually delivered
he continues to deliver on behalf of
millions of americans
so if you're getting a vaccine today you
can thank president trump because he was
the one that put forth that plan
and you know what and backing up that
money you know it's going to be very
very interesting where though
if you look at the trump presidency and
everything the president tried to do
democrats were taking him to court i
don't see the same thing happening to
the biden campaign except for there are
exceptions like the
attorney general in texas and some other
states
i've got to believe there's going to be
got to be some coordinated effort to
stop
the executive action joe biden said i'm
not a dictator
i got to get the votes man come on man
and all of a sudden he's not getting any
votes he's just writing executive order
after executive order
well it's coming i can tell you i
appreciate you you mentioning that
because
whether it is attorney general paxton in
texas or
attorney general uh landry in louisiana
or
many of the other great republican
attorney generals we have
stephen miller at american first legal
is going to actually be working
hand in glove with those attorney
generals working with
conservative partnership to actually go
forward and
challenge some of these executive
actions as
unconstitutional and and certainly they
need to be
uh held accountable and i can tell you
that help is on the
on the way uh american first legal is
going to be doing exactly what you're
talking about working with attorney
generals from across the country all
right but
looks like you got some sleep in the
last month i don't know you look a
little rested it looks like you even got
a little son
uh good to see you uh mark meadows